voilà tout est prêt
à vous est déjà arrivé bonjour j'attends
casimir qu'il a à venir travailler ces
exercices de danse il est en retard
comme d'habitude
casimir adorent danser mais ça l'ennuie
de travailler vers certain côté je le
comprends ça n'est pas toujours très
drôle
seulement pour être un grand danseur il
faut travailler énormément
la vie est belle je suis en pleine forme
je crois que le voilà
casimir
je sais que tu te caches
et que tu es là
de toute façon ça ne servira à rien
plus tu viendras tard plus ta leçon
commence rattache au
je n'ai pas envie de travailler je ne me
sens pas bien du tout oui tu veux le
faire croire que tu es malade oui je
suis malade oui j'ai mal à la tête pion
pied ouais j'ai mal aux moeurs si mal au
ventre au coeur donc c'est là qu'un
encore aux ions et j'ai même malouda au
menteur tu n'as pas dedans ah oui c'est
vrai j'avais oublié et inventer des
excuses et au travail dimanche qu'il
faut y aller
alors comme d'habitude première position
1 2 grand plié à
2 3 4 5 6 7 8
elle est bien tiré 1 2 3 4
c'est dur que ça julie bon je vais faire
les mouvements avec toi
2 tu sais c'est beaucoup plus facile
avec dans
deux oui mais il tend il faut que
j'aille me changer de tenue alors
pendant que je m'en vais tu continues à
travailler tes muscles pour qu'ils
refroidissent pas bon je reviens tout de
suite dépêche-toi un bon alors
2 3
et 4
c'est pourquoi est ce que tu te tort-
comme ça tout seul il ne faut pas que
mes muscles refroidissent
t'arrêtes tu as raison tu ne t'arrêtes
surtout pas je voudrais même qu'il
chauffe suffisamment pour que ça fonde
un petit peu là c'est malin on écoute
quasi mur te fâche pas c'est d'avoir un
peu le sens de l'humour oui et bien toi
au lieu de faire de l'humour tu ferais
mieux de t'occuper de tes balles on
regarde on n'a presque plus un oui c'est
vrai j'ai j'avais pas pensé bon ben j'y
vais et toi continue à bien nos
seniors
2 3
3 2
bah qu'est ce que c'est c'est moi quand
j'étais bien
vous m'avez fait tellement peur quand
j'ai failli tomber à ça alors je suis
déçu un casimir j'allais justement
félicité me féliciter bon source c'est
la première fois que je te vois tu
envolé à une grâce
oui bien c'est mal vous verrez quand je
saurai le plus grand danseur du monde
vous rirez moi et j'entends que tu veux
devenir le plus grand danseur du monde
ouah et pour cela je m'entraîne tous les
jours quand on sait que mon cher et 1000
ma part je n'ai jamais rien entendu
d'aussi koubbi remarquez je ne voudrais
pas accabler ce pot en casimir mais
il faut bien reconnaître que tous ces
exercices de danse sont déraisonnables
et les responsables du top-10
raisonnable c'est bien ou c'est pas bien
et bien déraisonnable c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a pas toute sa raison oui à toi de
juger si c'est bien ou pas bien mais
alors c'est pas bien en tout cas casimir
tous ces exercices sont absolument
inutile car la dose comme tous les
autres arts est un don un don qui est
donnée comme son nom l'indiqué aux
personnes de qualité ou pour sûr on a
une opinion intéressante
dit
vous en connaissez vous des gens qui ont
le don de la danse ouais moi bien sûr eh
bien vous verrez je suis persuadée
d'être meilleurs danseurs que vous avec
mes exercices plutôt que voir pouvons
dont et moi je suis tout à fait que son
avis merci ma très chère amie que de
joie de vous voir mais ne me dites pas
que vous n'êtes point de mon avis une
danseuse aussi doué que vous même
monsieur du snop moi je m'entraîne tous
les jours comme tous les danseurs la
danse est un art très difficile suffit
pas d'être doué pour réussir il faut
travailler sans 500 alors à bien je ne
cite pas vous tenez absolument à
défendre votre élève
julie fait c est je te donne entièrement
raison leur fasse ça vaut la peine de
travailler si on a des chances de
devenir un grand dans certains aspects
dans le cas de tous les cas c'est
milliard et polar magazine ne pense pas
mal du tout il a un grand sens du rythme
deuxièmement c'est un exercice excellent
plat dans ce même canton n'est pas un
grand danseur et puis vous 3 au lieu de
vous moquer de casimir vous pourriez
peut-être en faire autant françois tu ne
serais pas si essoufflé après harvard
[Rires]
vous seriez peut-être un peu plus
semaines et mois fatigué à la fin de la
journée
quant à vous ces dix non je ne suis
quand même pas trop gros enfin c'est
trop maigre regardez vous l'avez pas de
muscles tous les trois ça vous ferait le
plus grand bien croyez-moi de danser
comme casimir
voile
[Musique]
ça y est j nous pouvons commencer les
exercices très bien tout le monde à la
barre un deux roues jambes en l'air à
deux facteurs rentrent et levante
suivait
on repose représ paration à 2 monsieur
du snav ne vous tortillon n'est pas
comme un macaroni on recommence cette
fois petit battement sur les coups de
pieds à 2 à 2 ensemble s'il vous plaît
première position flexion avant étirez
vous tous monsieur duchesneau vous êtes
très tôt mme pitt ou bien casimir
2 recommençons les pieds ouverts
facteurs les genoux tendu